Alright.
Welcome back to computer vision.
Today we're going to continue.
Well actually we just
introduced tracking and
now we're actually going to do some.
So, remember last time
we talked about the difference
between detecting and tracking.
Detecting, we have some operator and
we just find or
whatever our target is in every frame.
In tracking, we're going to predict
a new location of an object.
Or the, the expected distribution
location of an object using estimated
dynamics, so somehow we're estimating
the velocity, accelerations, whatever.
And then we're going to update based
upon the measurements that we take.
So that's sort of the shall we say
the intuitive way of describing it.
What we're going to do this lesson,
the next lesson, the lesson after that,
the le, I don't know.
Probably for the next eight or
seven, 12 years or so.
What we're going to do is, we're
going to make this, much more formal.
And basically,
tracking as a form of inference.
And what we mean by that is, we're
going to have some state of the objects.
Some state we're trying to estimate.
We're going to call that x.
That's the parameters we care about.
But we don't actually know that.
So we refer to that as being hidden.
And we have a sensor.
Typically, it's going to be a camera for
the stuff we're talking about.
And what it's doing,
it's taking some measurements.
It's, it's measuring, like, our raw
detections that we're doing before.
And we're going to refer to
those as noisy observations
of whatever the underlying
state actually was.
The system that we're assuming is
that every time step t, the state,
the underlying state changes
from x of t minus 1 to x of t.
So here we have x of
t minus 1 to x of t.
And then at time t,
we get a new observation.
We get a new measurement.
And our goal, your mission,
should you choose to accept it,
is to recover the most likely state,
time t.
Now I was thinking about that,
its actually, that's not quite right.
What you want to do is you really want
to estimate not the most likely state.
I'm going to cross that out and
say the distribution or density.
So, if I have the density, that is I, I
have some belief about where x might be,
I can tell you the most likely place
that would be the highest probability.
I can tell you the average guess.
That would be the expected value but
the idea is that we're
going to have a density.
And, so your goal is to recover or
estimate this distribution given first
of all everything you've seen so far.
Right?
So you've been taking measurements all
along since last Tuesday.
Where is this thing now?
And the other thing that was given
to you was some knowledge or
some model of the state dynamics,
that is how this thing moves.
Then you may have to estimate some of
the parameters but you may know that
you know, I'm, I'm going to assume that
this thing has a particular velocity and
the acceleration is just some noise.
That would be a, a model that
you're going to assume is known.